economía en france24 buena noche para
todos buena noche daniela blandón ya me
acompaña en el estudio hablemos de los
bancos centrales del mundo que ya
comienza a analizar las monedas
virtuales así de raúl muy buenas noches
el primero en intentarlo será china su
banco central anunció hoy que emitirá
monedas digitales por valor de 15
millones de dólares a 50 mil
consumidores seleccionados al azar esta
campaña se produce justo cuando los
principales bancos centrales del mundo
incluida la reserva federal compiten por
emitir monedas virtuales para modernizar
los sistemas de pago pero otra de las
razones es que quieren defenderse de la
potencial amenaza de las cripto monedas
que cada vez toman más fuerza y que
representan ciertos riesgos de seguridad
a partir de hoy algunos habitantes de la
ciudad de shenzhen serán escogidos para
usar esta moneda y comprar en casi 4.000
puntos minoristas ya después de ir a
otras partes del país de raúl
así es àngel el banco mundial empeoró su
previsión de crecimiento para américa
latina
si la caída de la demanda externa y el
desplome del turismo serán los factores
que más golpeen a la región más afectada
por la crisis según este organismo
multilateral las proyecciones económicas
son cada vez más sombrías de raúl como
vemos en abril cuando comenzaba la
pandemia el banco mundial esperaba una
contracción del 4 6% para 2020 ya en
junio era más pesimista y creía que el
crecimiento iba a ser negativo en 72 % y
ahora acaba de presentar un nuevo
informe en el que apunta a una calidad
del 7 9% argentina méjico brasil serán
los principales damnificados de estas
contracciones
las buenas noticias vendrán el próximo
año cuando el banco mundial cree que la
economía pasará de caer a crecer un 4%
en américa latina y una buena noticia
entonces para los dominicanos porque el
gobierno de ese país desistió de subir
los impuestos
mire el recién llegado presidente del
país luisa mi vida nerd había enviado al
congreso un proyecto de presupuesto para
el próximo año con varios impuestos
incluidos la propuesta era grabar la
prima navideña también conocida como el
sueldo 13 también imponer una tarifa del
3 por ciento a las compras en modelo en
moneda extranjera con tarjeta de crédito
así como al uso de servicios digitales
otro de los impuestos era del 8% sobre
las ganancias extraordinarias de
aquellas empresas que hayan obtenido
utilidades durante la pandemia pero la
cascada de quejas que recibió el
mandatario hizo que diera marcha atrás y
que dijera que para este año abro
comillas no habrá nuevos impuestos para
el pueblo dominicano
daniela y continúa la polémica con tic
toc pakistán prohibió este viernes la
popular red social china
raúl el regulador de comunicaciones en
ese país dijo que su decisión se debe a
que ha recibido varias quejas de que
esta aplicación china no filtra el
contenido que denomina inmoral e
indecente esta misma razón había llevado
al bloqueo de otras aplicaciones como
tender y grinder en un país de mayoría
musulmana cuyas normas y costumbres son
bastante conservadoras
julia las autoridades le habían dado a
dictó un ultimátum para darle baja a sus
vídeos que eran considerados obscenos
pero no lo hizo y ahora a sus 14
millones de usuarios se quedarán sin
este servicio tick tock se ha vuelto muy
popular raúl pero al mismo tiempo varios
países han mostrado preocupación sobre
la privacidad de los usuarios por ser de
china india ya lo prohibió y eeuu va por
el mismo camino
así es daniele le pregunto entonces
ahora por los indicadores como cerraron
esta semana bueno 'wall street' despidió
su mejor semana desde agosto a la espera
de nuevos estímulos económicos el nasdaq
fue el más favorecido de la jornada en
europa las bolsas ganaron con excepción
de madrid
alentadas por declaraciones del
presidente de donald trump a quien da la
idea de que va a haber un nuevo rescate
que tiene que negociarse entre
republicanos y demócratas y en américa
latina la bolsa mexicana suspendió sus
negociaciones a media jornada de este
viernes sin dar explicaciones pero
terminó con una alza ligera para
finalizar daniela que nos tiene como si
fuera el día
486 millones de dólares que otorgó el
gobierno de eeuu
astrazéneca plc esto para desarrollar y
asegurar el suministro de 100 mil dosis
con anticuerpos de kobe 19 para todos
sus ciudadanos este es un medicamento
similar al que se usó para tratar al
presidente de donald trump así es hay el
entonces ya terminamos el bloque en
deporte el bloque económico
por el momento muchísimas gracias por
toda la información ustedes también
gracias por siempre acompañarnos aquí en
france 24
[Música]